[Music]  it's time for ETS social study your  quick look at what the Stars are posting  online and the Watson versus the Beehive  icon decide here it's more mortifying  for Beyonce fans are calling Emma out  for being a hypocrite after she clapped  back at online haters who called her  racy Vanity Fair shoot anti-feminist at  the time the Beauty and the Beast star  said feminism is about giving women  choice not bringing women down but  apparently she criticized Queen B in  2014 for doing the same thing in her  self-titled visual album emma shared the  full extra of her comments on twitter  where she applauded Beyonce's message of  female empowerment to cool the flames  meanwhile Ellie Goulding is getting into  fighting shape  the singer shared this killer workout on  Instagram who knew she could box and  Jessica Simpson is looking better than  ever  rocking denim from her clothing line in  these new campaign shots  [Music]  you